I have always thought of myself more as
a fox than a hedgehog and I Columbia
being a fox worked out really well and
it was Columbia it gave me that ability
to become myself the lively exciting
unusual urban place that it is it always
turns me on I give to bar nerd because
of the transformative effect it had on
my life margarita Bros Barnard College
1984 partnered changed my life in a lot
of different ways to be here in this
courtyard reminds me of being a freshman
my first day on campus I was a very shy
young woman before i came to Barnard but
here I was encouraged to be and take the
reins and do what I wanted to do and i
started a acapella group on campus which
is still in existence today the picante
and when i joined the track team i
noticed the need for leadership and i
took it and and became the captain of
the team my senior year being president
of the Alumni Association of the college
was what really brought me back in into
the arms of the college and to getting
to know the young women that are here
today and that more than anything has
kept me even more inspired about keeping
him involved with the college and
committed to its future that I'd always
wanted to create a scholarship and I had
the means to do so through some matching
funds for Michael my company I said well
you know I was involved varsity
athletics it would be lovely to for that
to go to a varsity athlete and I've had
the privilege of meeting every young
woman that has received that scholarship
to date I went to several other schools
but bartered is where I spend all my
time
and give a most of my money James
leitner School of International and
public affairs I've always been
incredibly curious about almost anything
most people think about finances
something very rigorous economically
driven mathematically driven I invest it
in russian stocks after reading a book
review maybe it wasn't a good reason to
invest but was very successful it worked
out very well investing Russia in 2002
you know was a great time to invest
School of International Affairs was not
a school that said we are going to force
you to become the best doctor or the
best engineer but they said the world's
a big place there are lots of ways to
think about the world one of the things
that I have been very involved with has
been establishing student internships to
send students abroad so that they can
themselves explore the world do research
meet people it's been an incredibly
rewarding experience I love giving back
giving back to Colombia has been just a
pure pleasure it doesn't pay to wait for
the school to come to you and ask you to
do something when you notice if
something needs doing just going to it
grab some alumnus go and do it create a
group of friends go and do it I think
that is how we change the world to the
better and that's how you change
Columbia for the better
pellet Coleman efforts school of general
studies 19-7 being a college student
bryn mawr was a class of nineteen fifty
there I got engaged right away I got
married and had children and I found I
was missing something in my life I
decided I really wanted to finish my
degree and where to do it so I looked
around and everybody told me the place
to do it was Columbia general studies
and suddenly that the world the life of
ideas became important to me so when I
became a teacher that was exactly what
my whole life had been leading me toward
it was Columbia it gave me that ability
to become myself that main activity I
have done was I started the Friends of
general studies and we met here once a
month in this room and we made plans for
a dinner every year that was given in
loan library and it was for the Alumni
to get them to come back to the school
and it was to show our new york city
friends that Columbia existed was a very
exciting place to be we were very much
the stepchild of the campus and we felt
that very strongly another thing our
group did was to lobby to get a ba for
our graduates rather than the BS that we
had been given here i am part of this
great institution walking in his
academic parade and the day before I had
handed out awards at general studies and
that to me was wonderful very exciting
my wildest dreams I have never thought
that I too could be wearing a cap and
gown at a Columbia graduation
Stephen H case Columbia College and the
law school what I always liked best
about Columbia was when the professor
was answering questions you could see
the thoughtful mind at work processing
something that was new or slightly
different then I always found that to be
very illuminating and I had a wonderful
very stimulating excellent legal
education from Columbia that serves me
well every day i love the university I
if I'd been a better student ID be
working for one and I just love being
around you hear about research and
scholarship and it's just so exciting
it's much more interesting than anything
else I do you are linked with the
institution and it's a two-way street
the institution needs support they don't
sell equity when they need more money
for expansion they have to depend on
philanthropy and the principal source of
philanthropy is slums and then there are
the continuing benefits that the
institution confers on you if it's a
prestigious highly regarded institution
like Columbia it helps you when that's
how you identify yourself and introduce
yourself to people congratulations I'm
so proud thank you very
it was a wonderful thrill to get the
melon I love being around I don't regard
myself as an important person I regard
myself as a faithful or polar somewhere
in the boat I don't think I deserve any
recognition so when you get it you say
wow me this is wonderful